the dog ate my homework thank God it was
gonna kill him
in a new study published in the Journal
of educational psychology researchers
found that there really is such thing as
too much homework when researchers from
Spain measured the academic performance
of 7725 private and public school
students in the math and science
they found that students who spend about
90 to 100 minutes on homework tend to
see their grades go on and decline while
those who study between 70 to 90 minutes
a day found a slight increase on their
grades all right I can honestly say that
in high school I barely ever did
homework I did my homework in the
classes before the class that I was
supposed to bring in the homework to do
in the first place
Trevon I was at your birthday party this
weekend I met some of your high school
friends they said you were a very good
student and that you did all your
homework on time do you think it was a
detriment or did it help you no I think
it was I mean listening to that those
numbers I think it helped because I was
in that 70 to 90 range I didn't have
that's 100 minutes of homework that
sounds crazy that's a lot of homework
yeah I remember having like two pages of
something to do the occasional end of
the semester like ten page report but
like a hundred minutes that's sounds
like a lot of homework especially when
curriculums have improved so it wasn't
like you had those teachers from like
the 90s or like 80s who like didn't
really give a [ __ ] how they were doing a
class here take this and go home and do
this right yeah but like now they're
actually teaching kids more and teaching
them better like curriculums and so I
get why adding a hundred minutes of
homework on top of that might make kids
a little like oh like this is exhausting
yeah I mean so I didn't do much I would
do homework in school as I said but or
I'd borrow it for somebody or so I did
figure it out a way but I was a pretty
good student overall but the idea of
this hundred minute thing or the idea
that these teachers feel or the
curriculum forces them to be like oh I
give this student 45 minutes of work
after we leave
it's not like an inherent flaw in the
teaching process like they have these
kids no you know these are they here
they have these kids all day right from
like 8 to 3 or whatever it is every
teacher that has a kid formate oh no but
you have that right so you have that kid
for an hour now or whatever it's been
but you get homework from each teacher
no that's that's my point that that
there's no way of balancing it quite
correctly and then you're just slamming
these kids and growing up also has
things to do that you find out about
things that aren't in books right I
completely agree that's completely true
I think part of the reason that this
study is a little bit misleading is that
we're pulling out a very small outcome
of the study and we're like obsessing
over this homework thing right but the
truth of the matter is this study was
trying to look at the effects of
homework overall and they accounted for
all these differences right like
socioeconomic status and gender and age
and all these different things and the
most salient thing that they found that
was more effective than all the other
factors combined was prior knowledge the
kids that were already more
knowledgeable going in always had higher
scores on standardized tests than the
kids that weren't combined that with how
much homework are they doing how how you
know personally driven is the homework
how autonomous is it all these little
like parsing is it 60 minutes is it 70
minutes is it a hundred minutes those
are very small almost statistically
insignificant effects the most
significant effects here were that the
kids were knowledgeable and that the
kids were self driven in doing their
homework so I think the thing that's
important to remember is that if you're
already a shitty student and then you
sit there for an hour every day or two
hours every day staring at the page it's
not going to help it might actually make
you more tired the next day when you go
in to take the exam right but if you're
a student who's already really into it
and you know how to do your homework
it's actually probably going to help if
you go home and do independent reading
and independent study
yeah so where is the school that I was
always looking for the school that you'd
go to during the day and the second you
get out of there they don't want to know
anything about you till the next day and
if anything they tell you to get out
there and run around and be outside
right place more like what why don't we
have more of that is that school really
going to help prepare you for your how
many times Dave do you leave work and
literally not think about work until you
show up the next morning well now that I
think about it all we also we also love
what we do though I think right the fact
that like even when I got here yeah I
couldn't stop watching the news and I
that not even trying is just like a
habit or it's like this is the thing
that I'm interested in so I ended up
turning it on I go what the [ __ ] am i
doing turn it off like go have fun this
is my vacation but I think for people
like us like I assumed we were all
driven students who liked what we were
who cared about education and so
homework and that stuff came natural and
easy to us and I had a lot of friends
who were shitty students and a part of
continuing to be a shitty student having
shitty teachers and having shitty
programs and that schools not having
money so those kids can like you were
saying continue to be shitty students
and the teacher started to focus on the
kids that they see promising and they
kind of like fall away from those kids
but that kids not going anywhere right
so it seemed I'm president so I'm gonna
focus on him and I got a classroom
that's oversized I got 40 kids seven of
them are great and the other like 33 are
mmm
so if I can with my thirty thousand
dollar salary make something out of
these seven kids I'm gonna focus on
these seven kids yeah I mean that's a
really great point because then it's so
systemic that it's not even the teachers
fault in it yeah it's a they don't have
the manpower at a time or the resource
you have to choose between who do I try
to like loosely educate this entire
class and don't give and give them a
watered-down education or try to really
get something out of these kids that I
see potentially and also try to help
these other kids even though chances are
like I went to school in Compton so I've
seen it all like I've seen teachers who
didn't give a [ __ ] and just put on a
movie and I've seen teachers who really
care like part of the reason I got into
writing and really focused on it was
because I had a teacher pull me aside
and say you're really good at this you
should focus on this more and had that
not happened I probably wouldn't be
doing what I'm doing because I was just
playing sports and going to class yeah
well you could have been an NBA player
maybe well I had yeah a little sliver of
all these numbers just think about how
much culture plays into this like you
were talking about growing up in Compton
it's not cool to be good at so yeah when
you live in these areas if we felt that
yes I have social pressure to to not be
into knowing things I have made fun of
for that like we talked about it which
is so sad we talked about the fact that
we love our jobs and that makes us want
to work when we get home hmm kids are
supposed
still love knowing stuff learning stuff
like being aware of the world around
them but when we take all of the joy out
of education and when we reinforce in a
social way that it's uncool to be smart
and that it's uncool to be challenged
and to know stuff what do you think is
going to happen I think that that's the
core detriment here is that we are not a
society that really promotes being
special and being smart and being
intellectual look at Congress right now
you know yeah this is not a core value
that we promote in our society all right
so I think there you go if you want to
be like Congress don't do your home if
you want to be like these three great
people right here do your homework
anyway let us know what you think in the
comments right now